well in a moment we're going to get the
thoughts of our political editor beth
rigby who's in Westeros the first say
let's go to our economics editor Edie
Conway well what do you make of it well
it was it was slightly bigger I think
that many people had expected you have a
lot of different measures and you've
kind of run through a lot of them there
some people thought there might be a v80
cut temporarily some people thought
there might be a stamp duty cut other
people's we're talking about the idea of
vouchers in the event we got all three
of them plus extra measures as well it's
worth just remembering and this was
something the chance there kind of you
know emphasized a number of times you
know this is part two of a three act
saga that we're having over the course
of this year the first part was all
those emergency measures we had when
lockdown was imposed now what we're
getting are measures to try to ensure
that basically the UK can start to come
off some of that emergency medicine so
you have the schemes to ensure that
companies don't necessarily layoff
people when they come back off the
furlough scheme you've seen something
similar to that in the u.s. now we have
it in the UK so that's the bonus of job
retention bonus and you've got measures
to try to ensure that people carry on
spending particularly in restaurants so
you had the VA tea cart that's very big
indeed in fact we probably have a look
at some of these costumes because they
have released the table with some
costings the v80 car actually cost 4.1
billion but what you can probably see
there is the bit that I've circled
that's the eat out to help out discount
now that is gonna attract up a lot of
attention isn't it you know this new
voucher whereby you can get money off
when you go out to use up to a discount
as you can see the bottom there of 10
pounds a head but it doesn't cost much
actually that's the least significant of
all of the measures that we've heard
about today half a billion pounds
compared with over four billion pounds
when it comes to restaurants vot being
cut temporarily just above it and look
at the bottom just just just above the
total stamp duty 3.8 billion pounds to
cut samp duty now that is a very big cut
indeed and some people might ask whether
that's consistent with the rest of this
package it was supposed to be a package
about jobs certainly that will help with
some of the jobs but there is
speculation as well that really the
stamp duty holiday is what number 10
wanted most of all the Treasury wasn't
entirely keen on it but number 10 have
got their way there's a stamp duty
holiday that goes in there that will
certainly help people who want to buy at
the moment
in practice in practice stamp duty whole
days like this stamp duty cuts like this
tend to benefit the home seller rather
than the buyers as counter factual as
that might sound it tends to be the
buyers middle-class homeowners who
benefit most from these policies but
nonetheless look across there and you're
talking about up to thirty billion
pounds it might be unlikely to get up to
thirty billion pounds it depends on how
many people come back from work for the
furlough scheme and how big that bonus
scheme costs but as I say this is stage
two acts two whatever you want to call
it and we're going to get act three in
the autumn that might well be even
bigger because that's when we get a
spending review get more detail on where
the government wants to spend extra cash
we get more detail on what kind of
measures it's going to put in place
permanently as opposed to the temporary
stuff that we've heard about today but
nonetheless it was more than a lot of
people expected and a lot of measures
there to try to ease the difficulties of
coming off this extreme form of economic
medicine that the country's on at the
moment and thank you Beth the Chancellor
described his plan for jobs as
unencumbered by Dogma so what's the
politics
well Adam it's a chance to really that
likes to under-promise ahead of the
statement and then over deliver if you
like in terms of what he announced it
was definitely more than people were
expecting the government has been under
huge pressure to extend the furlough
scheme beyond October at least for some
sectors that was Labor's big policy and
so what did he do well he pulled a
rabbit out of the hat in terms of what
we want necessarily expecting which was
this plan the job retention bonus and
what that's designed to do is to
encourage firms to keep on staff through
November to January a thousand-pound
bonus if they do that now there's nine
million people the government saying it
could cost them up to nine point four
billion if they do that whether they get
to that level is a completely different
matter but it was definitely designed to
take the wind out of labor sales and
design to reinforce this sentiment that
it's not jobs jobs
jobs that is Labour's policy but it is
actually the government policy and
that's exactly what mr. Cenac was doing
but in terms of the bigger politics for
the party certainly what they wanted was
the Chancellor to inject confidence here
to get people spending what are the
party looking for what's the government
looking for they're looking for a
v-shaped recovery and in the next few
months the charts will be desperate for
the economy to bounce back and you know
why by what he said at the beginning of
that statement let's just remember he
said hardship lies ahead no one left
without hope but the IMF says this is
going to be the deepest global recession
since records began and so look just to
put the scale of the task into one
sentence said you know in two months the
economy has contracted by 25 percentage
points that's the same it grew in 18
years that is the scale of his challenge
they wanted to project confidence how
did the opposition react well as one
senior opposition minister said to me
the jobs retention scheme by far was the
biggest measure and that there is some
good in this package but gaps remain
what about aerospace automotive sectors
at key manufacturing what about
companies that can't brings back staff
from furlough because they're still not
up and running the arts set to a big
package what about the beauty industry
what about nightclubs for example so
there's still areas where opposition
politicians would say are being left
behind and then others like the SMP said
well look at Germany Angela Merkel's
stimulus package to rebuild the German
economy was a hundred and thirty billion
euros against up to 30 billion pounds
that the government are announcing now
but what recession is doing is he's
buying time to try and get the economy
to bounce back to as IDI was pointed out
in October oh sorry in the autumn to
actually build the proper budget the big
fiscal package of big tax and spending
decisions so this is a stopgap if you
like to try and fuel demand and bounce
the economy back or at least begin to
try and grow it as the government looks
to see what the scale of the damage
really is going to be